the batman is 176 minutes of gritty well
executed noir inspired action but it
also has some major flaws
why is the penguin missing an iconic
accessory why is bruce so mean to alfred
spoilers ahead as we pick the batman
apart
paul dano's deranged and brilliant take
on the riddler is certainly a highlight
of the batman he's menacing and sadistic
and also pitiable and neurotic it's
honestly the most faithful
interpretation of the character in that
regard if not necessarily the most fun
that said what is not so faithful is his
new costume from the neck down it's
mostly forgivable given director matt
reeves grounded take on the universe but
his goofy try-hard zodiac inspired mask
is much less so that's mainly because
it's so different from any comic book
version of the character who has always
shown his face with only a domino mask
hiding his identity heck dano's thick
glasses seemed like a good grounded
version of a domino mask anyway to be
fair in the film the riddler wears the
mask because he needs to hide his
identity while streaming his
jigsaw-esque crimes to the internet
still doesn't make the mask any less
ridiculous
in many ways the riddler is indeed one
of batman's most clever and intelligent
villains it's because he thinks several
steps ahead of anyone else and is
usually undone solely due to his own
hubris rather than any lack of innate
brilliance also in the comics most
notably the batman event series hush the
riddler finally finds out batman's true
identity as the billionaire trust fund
baby bruce wayne even jim carrey's
over-the-top orange flat-topped jokester
version found out batman's secret
identity in 1995's batman forever so
it's somewhat disappointing that paul
dano's riddler can't connect the dots
and discover that batman is in fact goth
loner bruce wayne especially considering
how much riddler apparently loathes him
and presumably exhaustively researches
him oh you're really not as smart as i
thought you were
to be clear he also doesn't really care
who the batman is so he doesn't seek his
identity out it just seems given the
kind of research he does for all his
other victims that he would uncover that
fact regardless of intent
ever since the penguin's introduction in
1941's detective comics number 58 he's
had his trusty and iconic weaponized
umbrella at his disposal in fact every
incarnation of the penguin has had some
form of umbrella weapon at this point
which makes sense given that the
penguin's umbrella is probably his most
definable trait outside of his top hat
and overly pointy nose
take it easy sweetheart
this brings us to the umbrella and top
hat free version of the penguin in the
batman while it makes some sense to
ditch the outdated top hat to remove the
umbrella entirely seems a step too far
it doesn't have to turn into a
helicopter or anything it just needs to
be there even worse there's a scene set
during a heavy downpour of rain and
while his goons have umbrellas the
penguin himself doesn't that's just
rubbing salt in the wound
pretty much every batman film at this
point has a requisite batmobile car
chase scene in it it's happened so much
that it's become part of the batman
movie formula and why not the batmobile
is probably the hero's most famous and
versatile weapon in his fight against
crime and furthermore car chases are
always cool and have been an action
staple since the silent movie era the
batmobile car chase in the batman is no
exception it's got some neat shots big
explosions and the twisted metal and
screeching tires you'd expect however
it's also perfunctory and mediocre it
doesn't help that it's filmed at night
with a lot of close-up angles and uses
rapid edits compare that to the
spectacular tumblr chase scenes in
batman begins or the dark knight or even
the bonkers car chase in batman forever
where the batmobile drives up the side
of a building there's nothing nearly
that imaginative in the batman chase but
unfortunately it suffers in comparison
catwoman is one of the most iconic
characters in the batman comics and
arguably his healthiest romantic
relationship so it makes sense that matt
reeves would want to include her in his
new reboot furthermore zoe kravitz's
portrayal of catwoman aka selena kyle is
an instant classic
kravitz gives kyle a sense of real
strength and drive as well as a
sensitivity that slowly emerges
throughout the film without ever
sacrificing her edge or determination
not only that but she also has the
character's slinky feline movement down
pat and it actually looks like she can
believably kick the butts of goons two
to three times her size so it's such a
disappointment that the script lets her
down at every turn sure she gets to wail
on some faceless thugs with some flashy
moves but in every critical moment
whether it's getting subdued by batman
and their introduction beaten down by
carmine falcone or needing to be saved
in the climax from riddler's army like a
damsel in distress catwoman never really
gets a chance to come out on top
unlike the previous entry so far this
one is more about a narrative choice
that was meant to upset fans in the new
film bruce and alfred have a much more
fraught and tense relationship than they
normally do while alfred obviously cares
about bruce and is even instrumental in
helping decode the riddler's complicated
ciphers bruce doesn't seem to share that
affection
in fact in their first scene together
bruce snaps at alfred for trying to get
him to do stuff for his company even
saying you're not my father like an
angsty team
later on in the film bruce even chides
alfred for his wayne family cufflinks
implying that alfred isn't worthy of the
wayne name this of course is upsetting
because we like to see alfred and bruce
have affection for each other and
bruce's dismissiveness to his devoted
butler father figure isn't fun to watch
spoiler warning this section contains a
major plot point from spider-man no way
home
like the previous entry watching alfred
get consumed by flames and presumed dead
is pretty purposefully upsetting for
fans worse is bruce realizing that the
riddler planned to kill bruce wayne with
alfred as potential collateral damage
and that his race against time was
futile because the bomb the riddler sent
had already exploded hours earlier this
scene is especially upsetting given what
happened to aunt may in last year's
spider-man no way home she was another
character in a superhero blockbuster
thought to be safe due to her longevity
in the comics making her subsequent
death that much more shocking and
disheartening in this case alfred does
turn out to have survived the riddler's
attack which is good because the loss of
alfred might have been one too many
unexpected deaths of beloved characters
in such a short time span
one of the most intriguing aspects of
the batman is how it repositions the
morality of the wanes and actually adds
a bit of moral ambiguity and realism to
this version of the universe in the film
it's revealed that thomas wayne was
running for mayor before he was killed
and that during the campaign a reporter
found out that martha whose maiden name
was arkham had family baggage that could
derail the election thomas then tried to
bribe the reporter to back off when he
didn't he asked his old friend mob boss
carmine falcone to step in and take care
of it which he did by killing the
reporter this is great because it gets
into how the rich are often embedded in
crime to maintain power unfortunately
while it gestures towards a more
complicated take on the wayne's
backstory it's ultimately half-hearted
and half-assed at one point alfred even
defends thomas wayne saying he was a
good man because he felt bad about his
mobster buddy killing an innocent person
worse the film thinks that's a good
justification
one of the most iconic comic book arcs
in batman history is nightfall which ran
from 1993 to 1994. it was the
introduction of bane a large
muscle-bound and luchador masked villain
who famously broke batman's back over
his knee now while bane is sometimes
characterized as being a big dumb brute
the bane in the comics is actually a
calculating tactician his strength
however is still formidable and
augmented by a chemical known as venom a
green liquid that is basically super
steroids
curiously there's a moment in the
climactic action scene of the batman
that alludes to the existence of venom
in this universe batman is seen reeling
from a shotgun blast to the chest and
eventually injects himself with green
liquid that gives him a boost of
strength to continue fighting and save
the day
true this could just be adrenaline but
the fact that it's so effective and
makes him go berserk for a moment seems
deliberate
it seems that every batman adaptation
feels the need to add the joker sure
he's an important part of the
character's mythos but there are so many
other crazy villains that would be much
more interesting to see in live action
at this point however if you are going
to do a new version of the joker you
have to at least do it well
unfortunately this might be one of the
weakest attempts at a reboot of the
clown prince of prime that we've seen
yet actor barry kyogen is very subdued
in the role for some reason
appearing bored and almost embarrassed
to perform the iconic laugh
this of course is not to discredit
kyogen as a performer outright he was
phenomenal in the killing of a sacred
deer where he was genuinely creepy and
unsettling opposite fellow the batman
villain colin farrell
it's obvious while watching the batman
that writer director matt reeves and
co-writer peter craig are trying to say
something with this film by discussing
things like income inequality rampant
police corruption systemic malfeasance
etc that's all well and good potentially
noble even the issue is what actual
statement are they making beyond these
things exist because the riddler isn't
wrong really the world is full of
corruption where the rich and powerful
exploit the poor and marginalized with
impunity it's a legitimate problem the
anger is justified it's so justified in
fact that the screenwriters had to
concoct a far-fetched plan to drown
gotham so that his points can be easily
ignored the solution the film comes to
seems to be reformation to regain trust
in institutions as said by belarus the
brave newly elected and progressive
coded mayor of gotham at the end of the
film however we've seen how reform
doesn't fix police corruption this
wouldn't be a problem in a less grounded
universe you're not questioning the
harsh realities in a tim burton movie
but in this more realistic film it just
comes off as wrong-headed even if it is
well intentioned
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you